It's a tyranny.
It's a tyranny of positivity.
And it's cruel.
Unkind.
And ineffective.
And we do it to ourselves,
and we do it to others.
If there's one common feature
of brooding, bottling or false positivity, it's this:
they are all rigid responses.
And if there's a single lesson we can learn
from the inevitable fall of apartheid
it is that rigid denial doesn't work.
It's unsustainable.
For individuals, for families,
for societies.
And as we watch the ice caps melt,
it is unsustainable for our planet.
Research on emotional suppression shows
that when emotions are pushed aside or ignored,
they get stronger.
Psychologists call this amplification.
Like that delicious chocolate cake in the refrigerator --
the more you try to ignore it ...
(Laughter)
the greater its hold on you.
You might think you're in control of unwanted emotions when you ignore them,
but in fact they control you.
Internal pain always comes out.
Always.
And who pays the price?
We do.
Our children,
our colleagues,
our communities.
Now, don't get me wrong.
I'm not anti-happiness.
I like being happy.
I'm a pretty happy person.
But when we push aside normal emotions to embrace false positivity,
we lose our capacity to develop skills to deal with the world as it is,
not as we wish it to be.
I've had hundreds of people tell me what they don't want to feel.
They say things like,
"I don't want to try because I don't want to feel disappointed."
Or, "I just want this feeling to go away."
"I understand," I say to them.
"But you have dead people's goals."
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Only dead people
never get unwanted or inconvenienced by their feelings.
(Laughter)
Only dead people never get stressed,
never get broken hearts,
never experience the disappointment that comes with failure.
Tough emotions are part of our contract with life.
You don't get to have a meaningful career
or raise a family
or leave the world a better place
without stress and discomfort.
Discomfort is the price of admission to a meaningful life.
So, how do we begin to dismantle rigidity
and embrace emotional agility?
As that young schoolgirl,
when I leaned into those blank pages,
I started to do away with feelings
of what I should be experiencing.
And instead started to open my heart to what I did feel.
Pain.
And grief.
And loss.
And regret.
Research now shows
that the radical acceptance of all of our emotions --
even the messy, difficult ones --
is the cornerstone to resilience, thriving,
and true, authentic happiness.
But emotional agility is more that just an acceptance of emotions.
We also know that accuracy matters.
In my own research, I found that words are essential.
We often use quick and easy labels to describe our feelings.
"I'm stressed" is the most common one I hear.
But there's a world of difference between stress and disappointment
or stress and that knowing dread of "I'm in the wrong career."
When we label our emotions accurately,
we are more able to discern the precise cause of our feelings.
And what scientists call the readiness potential in our brain
is activated, allowing us to take concrete steps.
But not just any steps -- the right steps for us.
Because our emotions are data.
Our emotions contain flashing lights to things that we care about.
We tend not to feel strong emotion
to stuff that doesn't mean anything in our worlds.
If you feel rage when you read the news,
that rage is a signpost, perhaps, that you value equity and fairness --
and an opportunity to take active steps
to shape your life in that direction.
When we are open to the difficult emotions,
we are able to generate responses that are values-aligned.
But there's an important caveat.
Emotions are data, they are not directives.
We can show up to and mine our emotions for their values
without needing to listen to them.
Just like I can show up to my son in his frustration with his baby sister --
but not endorse his idea that he gets to give her away
to the first stranger he sees in a shopping mall.
(Laughter)
We own our emotions, they don't own us.
When we internalize the difference between how I feel in all my wisdom
and what I do in a values-aligned action,
we generate the pathway to our best selves
via our emotions.
So, what does this look like in practice?
When you feel a strong, tough emotion,
don't race for the emotional exits.
Learn its contours, show up to the journal of your hearts.
What is the emotion telling you?
And try not to say "I am," as in, "I'm angry" or "I'm sad."
When you say "I am"
it makes you sound as if you are the emotion.
Whereas you are you, and the emotion is a data source.
Instead, try to notice the feeling for what it is:
"I'm noticing that I'm feeling sad"
or "I'm noticing that I'm feeling angry."
These are essential skills for us,
our families, our communities.
They're also critical to the workplace.
In my research,
when I looked at what helps people to bring the best of themselves to work,
I found a powerful key contributor:
individualized consideration.
When people are allowed to feel their emotional truth,
engagement, creativity and innovation flourish in the organization.
Diversity isn't just people,
it's also what's inside people.
Including diversity of emotion.
The most agile, resilient individuals, teams,
organizations, families, communities
are built on an openness to the normal human emotions.
It's this that allows us to say,
"What is my emotion telling me?"
"Which action will bring me towards my values?"
"Which will take me away from my values?"
Emotional agility is the ability to be with your emotions
with curiosity, compassion,
and especially the courage to take values-connected steps.
When I was little,
I would wake up at night terrified by the idea of death.
My father would comfort me with soft pats and kisses.
But he would never lie.
"We all die, Susie," he would say.
"It's normal to be scared."
He didn't try to invent a buffer between me and reality.
It took me a while to understand
the power of how he guided me through those nights.
What he showed me is that courage is not an absence of fear;
courage is fear walking.
Neither of us knew that in 10 short years,
he would be gone.
And that time for each of us is all too precious
and all too brief.
But when our moment comes
to face our fragility,
in that ultimate time,
it will ask us,
"Are you agile?"
Let the moment be an unreserved "yes."
A "yes" born of a lifelong correspondence with your own heart.
And in seeing yourself.
Because in seeing yourself,
you are also able to see others, too:
the only sustainable way forward
in a fragile, beautiful world.
Sawubona.
And thank you.
(Laughter)
Thank you.
(Applause)